the Joe Rogan experience you guys want
to start with song yeah let's start with
the song we'll start with a song bad
beast bad beast yeah alright okay
this is the first time we've like done
this together so holy [ __ ] yeah look out
folks
[Laughter]
[Music]
each day you go for my eyes dragon even
you like I'm your child kicking
screaming stuck on your leash killing
the cream just licking his teeth damn
[Music]
even in me chaining me up and send me
Frese we do it over and over again to
keep me down damned if I give in and
damned if I don't
[Music]
within yeah I'm trying to rise above I
try playing dead you can try calling up
that ghost in my bed and you just laugh
can catch his breath said he won no
match but Angely Depp that day
it's bad beats living in me you chain me
up it's Emily freezing do it over and
over I can't keep me down they'll be my
giving and if I don't
[Music]
very mean one day on Sunday mama
pray for me it's so very mean one day on
Sunday mama won't you pray for me
there's so barely a Sunday mom won't you
pray the me
[Music]
don't think that I'm weak I don't think
I'm unfit I don't think I've even seen
the fickle is [ __ ]
so I'll roll with the dirt these
bulldozing me it'll hurt a lot of hurt
carrying my grief goddamn
there's a bad beast
me
[Music]
[Applause]